the key phrase is general time which is
why I remembered are actually very
important to have in this TK plus 1
I don't amount and you'll be justing why
as I expect to work through the teachers
standard term okay so we know that this
think er when we Center the whole thing
is going to have a whole bunch of times
during how many and there were 11 times
because you're on the tenth row Pascal's
triangle is one on the side there will
be a letter terms there are no what any
particulars have individually will be
okay so what I like to start doing is
let's actually if you can't if you can't
remember through the top your head part
this is the way the formula works or
even if you can want to make sure you
get it right just think about what this
is going to be set up the pattern for
yourself and then the general term is
kind of follows up in them so we
remember everybody mule expansion every
time in the my new obsession is three
pieces two before the three pieces are
what is first here is that entry are get
right now let's just worry about that we
are on the tenth row of Pascal's
triangle because of this ten right so
this is going to be ten see the first
the first along the road it actually
zero a term remember that if anything so
this is this is why we're getting our
mapping of year texted you then we're
going to have some of these guidance on
these guides right those are the other
two components don't forget it is
actually a negative 1 over X so the
minus x got to come along for the ride
which one you want to start with Jonna
start with what the video report of this
little bit of it yeah I think so we'll
say there's going to be 10 of those
right we see how do you leave that on it
zero zero zero right that is that's the
whole first term of course you can
simplify it but it's more important
though what each of the pieces aren't
highly constructed because you otherwise
can't do
Janson we've won on the NCR it moves on
a lot so what I going to have tending
110v one everything we can see this can
see that these we started with one of us
it's going to ratchet down one we
started with none of these it's going to
go up by one
this agree is basically asking okay it's
now all the data for it is well okay I
now know what every single term is
basically the same format so now I don't
want to know what the particular term
going to be this in term 4 K ethane is a
term or just if you know this term 1
this is term - so in this format here
what they need by K R is a little bit
weird but hopefully it'll make synthetic
digit term 0 plus 1 this is terms 1 plus
1 so the 0 the K
not zero then became is this number and
this number right and it's also that
number in bit right because now when you
move the lot let's shuttle over
different colors of time the one is in
all the same spots right if here is here
and the night is actually 10 take away
one degree so now I can use that already
I can ask their therefore okay ah swine
is going to be equal to look at the
putts that are the same every time
there's always attempted every term has
that but is it depend on which each
other on it's not the difference okay
what is that number in the teacher +10
so TK plus 1 it's going to be okay are
do it's because this may change all
these changes you know can't be much and
these match having these percent yeah
how many of these x2 temperate Caleb
September zero to multi members to to
the Moses came and then lastly how many
you think maybe whatever actor they're
being there are going to be Caleb okay
now you're not done you okay because
you've got X's here and X's here you can
interact with each other okay so I'm
going to start to simplify this a little
bit this you just gotta hang up front I
mean could get back to real notation but
it doesn't simplify with anything else
it's there see just leave these has a
different them I'm going to first get a
right
this I'm going to pull part into two
pieces
okay do you agree that this is negative
1 times X to the P yeah that's okay they
don't have a part of K that means I'm
godparents ek2 the tail okay the day one
gets ready
^ okay and the X to the negative one
also gets ready to power K so I actually
got this these are going to be answered
her arm care just multiply those indices
for us and now I can see clear you
multiplying numbers with the same base
so the final line I'm going to put the
card together simply with and longitude
and it doesn't really know me I'm
approach it for better if it's another
but that's why okay you doesn't you have
identified correctly how the expansion
works
you've been generalized that's what we
call this these specific terms it's just
a general term and then you just have to
muck around with the algebra - you got
something like there's excess here here
is no reason to do that so we're done
would you say the general rule when you
don't wanted a fraction to slip it
around yeah so they leave it this is the
reason one we do this is because if you
think about the way in if he started and
start like this two squared - x - 2
cubed 2 times 2 times 2 to the 4 is 4
okay but then when you say oh what is 2
to the negative 1 meaning you can't be
another fit this definition
regular bid how do you multiply
something by itself negative 1 times so
you have to think okay well let's just
look at the pattern this is 16 this is a
this is 4 I guess that means if I go
back one
or that will be too because of dividing
if I go that one more that'll be one
that's when we get a zero count one and
if I go back one was still divided by 2
every time which leaves me with my home
so that's why that's why the result is
very difficult